paul hancock
rick you talked about pops is one of
your favorite suits i didn't i love pops
canadian pops are way better gotta have
my pops i don't know most things from
canada are much much worse oh listen
paul you've become the uh third worst
hancock after john and herbie yeah
americans you know you [ __ ] i mean i
love herbert
herbie hancock [ __ ] that guy rules
beast
pops suck i love pups pops are the most
overrated cereal they're fine
they're [ __ ] fine they're great some
[ __ ] never tried crackling
oprah get out of here matt have you
tried crackling operand pick of the pops
you're like my grandfather over here
crackling oprah bew slicks you gonna
pull that out next the raisin bran come
on raisin bran is a solid cereal get
some cardboard in here we'll chop it up
we'll put some milk on it once you try
cracklin oprah i've never heard you're
gonna give the biggest apology to me and
i'm sorry kellogg's has a shortage matt
looked this up
they've assured it because everyone's
buying up crackling oat bran cause that
[ __ ] is underrated oh maybe it's more
like firestone where they had to get rid
of it it's off the shelf it's like deep
throat the girl's too young get rid of
it
the people the public shouldn't have it
it's crackling oberyn is
destroys pops
what are we uh shoeless with a with a
harmonica and a sitting on a porch
drinking a jug with three x's on it
crack that oat bread it just feels like
that's something backwoods deliberate i
i i look you're making funny lines mark
problem is it's a damn fine soup all
right all right i'll believe it when i
taste it and you'll taste it bring it in
matt i want it in i want it right here
i'm going to go nuts on this crack then
i don't feel like getting a [ __ ] box
in the crackling okay oprah was going to
be like national treasure here
all right insane it's like getting uh
some good meth or coca these days it's
hard to find i'll suck your dicks just
give me some crack
some crackling oatmeal uh-huh they
didn't even skimp on the names it was
like cracks smack all this [ __ ] is just
so drunk drug-laced
daddy's secret cough medicine i'll suck
your dick long time that's my favorite
cereal what are you what are you free
bracing over there nut and honey so we
get our heroin yes it's easy to get them
crackling oats i'll tell you that you
know what it's [ __ ] true
why are crackling notes so hard to get
you went on amazon didn't you we got to
go to the store in-house i bet they got
it there no no they didn't have it oh
really oh you went to the store all
right well let's try amazon
maybe they got it
somebody's got it online send us in
cracklin i know you're listening
crackling oh brand [ __ ] rocks i've
never heard of it i've never had i've
never seen it so i'll try pops and you
try crackling look at that box that box
from 81 and it still works [ __ ]
oh
what does that say 59
oh my lord this looks like a beanie baby
let's see the reviews on crackling
oh this is good stuff have you tried
that [ __ ] you know how good it is i've
never heard of it
i can't wait to try it i'm dying oh four
out of five star four point four out of
five seventy one percent give me the
sugar i would be worth the sugar amount
okay well we got the taste are we going
for what no there's a lot of sugar in
there all right we're going for sugar
we're going for taste
it's not worth it i'll pay five dollars
at a grocery store well that makes okay
but these are five stars for taste
yeah true
what did that say tasty and healthy and
that one says wish this cereal is in a
bigger box okay
yeah it did
i love the cereal
and in fact i'm due for another
five stars from tokyo it's a good ass
cereal snack tokyo this shit's global
[ __ ] i guess so crackling oat
bran love this cereal it's hard to find
one person found this helpful oh sorry
five stars
nice to have this source okay so people
are looking for it i i'm not i'm not
saying it's bad i've never had it once
you try it dude the apologies are going
to come rolling in this [ __ ]
is epic matt i can't believe you've
never tried this was like [ __ ] heaven
for me really
there's not a better cereal i don't
think all right well matt just gave it
two stars i don't know what that means
the [ __ ] man god damn it that was that
was tough try someplace other yeah but
two stars because overpriced not because
of the quality right right
all right all right people seem to enjoy
it so i'm not saying it's bad
it just seems rare well look what is
that a square get a close-up on that
i've never seen these this little the
shape this is all
all foreign to me yeah well also
cinnamon stick in the back so is it
cinnamony no uh here we go with the
health nutrition facts i don't want to
see that saturated fat got a lot of
sugars
monosaturated cholesterol not healthy
man
really too much cereal like it's healthy
good point good point you're talking
about lucky charms and [ __ ] come on i
mean that's
straight anthrax to the vein
how about fruity pebbles you ever [ __ ]
with that i love fruity pebbles but it's
a window with fruity pebbles it's too if
it's two in this the milk
it turns into [ __ ]
mush pudding horseshit
ah
look at that
some guy just saved the marshmallows
he's got a jar of marshmallows that see
that's too far you gotta have a little
rain without with the sun you can't just
go straight you're not an addict not an
addict
we gotta live in a society here jesus
christ